We're going to do just a little bit of
work today. I figured I'd do a shortish
stream. We'll see how well uh or how
long this goes. But
uh let me let me just sort of start and
show what I've been thinking about a
little bit. So,
fractic. Welcome. Um, so this here is
one of the curves
that we just found kind of randomly
during a sweep. Hey Tim,
you can see here we have a score of 20.5
in 13 seconds.
But if I do it in steps,
it's actually below two million steps.
Okay. And if I instead go to all of
these runs that are all good,
right? We can see that we have step
solves up to this is like five mil.
We've got 2 mil.
But then if we go by time,
you know, we get all the way from down
to 3 seconds up to anywhere over here.
So, uh, this means that this is a pretty
solid environment for
evaluating this tradeoff type of a
thing.
And I think we can even just do this,
right? If I just go
This this I need to find a better
replacement for this. This honestly
Neptune used to be good, but it's like
look how crap this thing is. Oh yeah,
250 search results. Let me just take
five seconds to search that.
Honestly, I should just Okay, so
we get a front here, right?
And actually, it should be
we care about the lower end of this
front here, right?
So this sort of curve, if we draw this,
right? We're getting this like this nice
fit here.
Didn't I get epic pen? I forgot I got
this for the stream.
Right. You see this sort of fit here?
This is what we're interested in.
We want to see
if we can spend
more compute versus more data.
I don't think that it needs to even be
this much compute. I think we can even
cut it at 30 because it's just running
the trials for too long. Even 20.
Even this like little chunk of the
frontier is useful to us.
This is going to be the graph that
matters in RL.
and timeout needs to go down to like
30 or 20.
20 spread me. Give it 30.
what we do with the
burrito frontier, right?
Is there a simple
If I make one cost metric out of it,
it's easy. But I don't think that's what
we want to do.
We just going to split it. Is that what
we're going to do?
can probably do both.
I'm actually a little curious here.
last
mention is the number of data point.
Maybe we can
wonder
All right. What happened here? Down
sampled.
You can't down sample this, huh?
Hello. Welcome.
I hate latte. Yeah,
papers are a pain.
Yeah, because like having trying to have
like a human hand mimic like the actual
physical operations is like the dumbest
conceivable way of doing that, right?
And just everything should be done
through the software. There.
Hey, how's it going?
If you're not using a debugger, you are
straight up trolling.
Welcome though. How are all your crazy
projects going lately?
debugging.
Yeah. For all the bugs that your LLM's
made, right, for you, right?
It's learning from pixels.
Frozen embeddings makes it learn 3x
faster.
You have to actually compute the
embeddings for your new data. Yeah,
which would be a bigger model
clock. H, that's amusing.
Well, I suppose it depends on the base
architecture you're using as well. Like
a lot of the from pixel stuff kind of
sucks. Um, if you use like the original
convenet architecture from uh like
Nature CNN or whatever, that's awful.
You can use the Impala one, which is a
slightly deeper ResNet, but it's
annoyingly slow. This is the reason we
don't do pixels, man. It's not cuz
pixels are a harder problem. It's just
cuz everything gets slow.
bonus is killing velocity. Yeah, it'll
do that.
Honestly, like I'm at a point here where
I have to do work on sweeps and it's
completely killing my motivation and the
individual experiments are only like 30
seconds, but you know, my whole
experiment is having to run at least a
hundred of those in a sweep.
I don't need to do it off vision alone.
I really wanted to. If you can just have
something set up where at least most of
your experiments can be done from state,
right? Even if you have to go division
later,
I I would try to do that very very
strongly
like cuz the other thing Yaxine right is
like you can train an encoder fully
supervised right like if you want to do
a frozen embeddings thing if you have a
good state-based policy that means that
you can actually generate yourself good
vision data right
like there's a lot that you can do
borrow 256 HS.
Also, H00's are usually not even faster
for RL. Like,
to be fair, I haven't tried really
heavily optimizing BF-16, so maybe. But
most of the time, our networks are so
small,
like they're not even faster.
connect on the embeddings also on CUDA
ray tracing or 800s. Yeah, 800s are
about like I'm pretty sure 4090s are
faster than 800s for most RL stuff.
Like I would just suggest if you want
cheap compute just go find on vast like
people have nice multiGPU boxes with
either 4090s or 5090s.
I would just do that.
I don't know if you can get access to
the RT cores as well, but the consumer
cards have RT cores in them. I don't
know if they're like nicely exposed in
the way CUDA is, but technically your
chips literally have hardware on them
for ray tracing. like that's it's that's
all it's designed to do. So, you should
be able to use That
Too much work. Going to try scaling on
CUDA
off state loop on that. Figure out how
to learn. Generate the state off the
sim. Yeah, that would be better.
I don't know what you're trying to do in
the latest crazy iteration of your your
stuff.
I did a really hard block of research
for like three weeks. I posted the
article on it, right? I like actually
found a I found a clear-cut mathematical
reason for a lot of the stuff I've been
saying for the last year or two. Um, I
know what to do next.
But yeah, I'm kind of just chilling and
doing a few things on this in the
meanwhile before I really start going on
the uh the next big push
and finishing this batshit crazy cut
that's driving me insane.
RL is very weird, but it's getting
better. I mean honestly that article
makes a lot of stuff make sense now,
right?
I think on the algo side the
the holy grail would be like a really
really clean method of using um
of combining like on policy RL
well
it's of combining long form
bootstrapping with data reuse. I suppose
that's what it is.
But even before I get there, I basically
figured out that I'm going to be able to
get like at least 10 to 20x sample
efficiency
uh just by fixing up my hyperprem
tuning.
So, we're going to do that first. We're
going to make puffer able to be, you
know, really the best thing out there
for anything from moderately fast to
very fast M, not just very fast M,
right?
and moderately fast M's you can usually
get by just scaling up slow M's for
practical stuff in industry that's what
I'm doing next and uh then from there
will be more opportunities
sweep I mean this is what I'm doing
right now is I'm working on here. I'll
show you the graph. This is going to be
the most important graph in uh in RL.
This is the crappy version of it, right?
Whoops. Let's not make it go below zero.
That's really dumb.
But yeah, this so this is going to be
the most important graph. This is the
data compute trade-off. So it's this
frontier.
Can I use more
compute to use less data or can I use
more data to use less compute and have
this automatically figure it out for you
for your specific problem
and ideally without all this squiggly
mess over there, right? Without all
these bad samples.
This is the thing I'm doing at the
moment.
Did you need pointers on uh any of the
rendering stuff or whatnot?
I mean, the biggest tip I can give you
is to do whatever it takes to keep that
dev loop tight.
It's really tough when it isn't
honestly. Good. That's good. I haven't
messed with uh rendering much for the
exact reasons that you're encountering
right now
and I like and I frankly have a ton of
other stuff that I can be doing outside
of that.
You ripped out my drone as ray tracer.
Yeah, that's exactly what I would have
suggested doing
on a pietorch stream.
On a pietorch stream.
Are you doing it just in PyTorch tensors
like pure pietorch tensor ops
or do you have uh it hooked in?
Ah jeez. So limiting. So the cool thing
with Madrona right is that you can write
arbitrary like you can do arbitrary CUDA
and stuff. Oh I have it hooked in. It's
a pietorch ex. It's an extension, but
it's not pure pietorch ops, right? Like
you can write arbitrary logic and loops
and stuff.
You're not doing like a Jax thing where
it's a just a bunch of tensor ops right
through Python. Okay, that's better.
Yeah, as long as you have that. as long
as you're not reinventing jacks in
PyTorch
because like the thing people forget,
right, is like you don't have to do
everything in bloody PyTorch to keep it
on the GPU, right? You can do it in CUDA
and the data can stay on the GPU and
just get cast to a a torch tensor for
free
physics and pietorrch
if it's simple. But I don't know. I
think you find rather quickly, right, if
you're going to be reinventing Jack
style stuff and you go read Jack's code
for more complicated projects, it's not
fun.
Collisions in the loop is faster.
Yeah. So, it's like once you start
adding stuff to it, right? Like once you
start trying to add more features and
stuff and then you realize ah crap I
need to do loops right it's then that's
when it's you just stop using the highle
thing and you use the lowle thing right
some cuda or whatever
Right. Couldn't make it an extension.
Yes, exactly. And we have an uh we have
a very small sample of that with my
advantage computation.
Right. Puffer has a a pietorch extension
for that.
Yeah, Super Maven's really nice, right?
It's really stupid, but it's really
fast.
So, if I if my brain were actually
working today, right, it's like you're
just no longer limited by typing speed.
This is all I use for codeex. And like I
don't do anything else.
I don't have the freaking bloated ass
agent this or that, right?
We have real agents around here.
Literally, the only thing that matters
is that the thing is good enough and
that it's fast.
Dude, I don't see how you have any get
any enjoyment out of like wrangling LLMs
all day. Like I would go batshit insane
and like go run away to a forest and
become a monk or some [ __ ] dealing with
that.
Yeah. So for me that's just equal to
typing buff, right?
Oh, I see it.
Maybe I value the control too much, but
I don't know. I don't like
I don't like stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] with my
code. And especially when it's not a
person who I can like actually give
feedback to who will improve over time.
I have a lot more focus though on the
I have a lot of focus on the code
itself, not the output. Like
Puffer is not just the output of what it
can do, right? Like the simplicity
and the structure of the code is a large
part of Puffer,
large part of programming for me really.
off policy RL for continuous.
So Rob, off policy RL is a mess for the
reasons I outlined in my most recent
article on X.
We do almost exactly on policy RL for
everything in Puffer. And there are
advantages to offpolar. They're
currently not worth it. And it's going
to require like a fundamental change in
RL capabilities to actually leverage
what offpol is good at effectively.
Don't read every single line.
Yeah. No, I hear you on that. It's just
I don't know. Spending all day reading
crap code instead of just writing a
little bit of good code myself.
Not my idea of a good time.
Cuz
it's like when stuff is done stupid, I
can't just go edit it line by line. I
have to redo the thing.
Yeah, this is a way way lighter weight
setup though than what it seems like
you've been posting about on X-ray.
Like this really doesn't do a ton for
you.
This just like eliminates typing speed
as a pretty much just eliminates typing
speed as a bottleneck.
You know, I'm not a crazy fast typer. I
can type maybe like somewhere between 80
and 100, maybe 90 on a good day WPM.
And then this is just like takes that to
effectively. And it's not like I'm going
to be writing the code so much faster.
It's more so just that like while I'm
thinking about stuff. It's like it
reduces the barrier of oh, I'd actually
have to like type that to try it.
Mhm.
Yeah. 110.
You will eventually be like a fast. Most
people would eventually be that fast if
you've been doing it for long enough,
right? In my case, like I just my hand I
have feet for hands. I don't know.
My decks is like the dump stat I guess.
blowing off Paul for my problem because
I'm data capped.
Yeah. So that's the hard thing. So Rob,
basically the article will outline
pretty much everything. Off-paul does
work, but it's very brittle and it can
literally be a thousandx slower than
onpaul. That's the problem. So like the
trade-off is it's scalable, but it's a
really really bad uh compute to data
like trade-off.
There's not like a good region of it.
Isn't that the chair?
Oh, no. That's the keyboard. The kinesis
keyboard.
No, that's not going to help.
I guarantee you that's not going to
help.
I don't know. My decks has always just
like just sucked, you know? Bad at every
game ever. Handwriting's bad. Write
super slow. That sort of a thing.
Yeah. I'll show you what I got.
What's this? Is this the old one? Okay.
Yeah. So, this is the old one. I have
the newer one at my uh uh at the other
place, but
see
Black Widow uh Tournament Edition V2.
I like it.
means you pay attention to detail. Not
particularly, I'm just slow on things.
The funny thing is it's really not that
big of a deal for most most stuff.
90 WPM versus like 120 doesn't actually
make a difference in your day-to-day
hardly at all.
Yeah, good keyboards. I mean, they're
over like people, as people say, a lot
of the Razer stuff is overpriced. Um,
but it is like pretty good. I have like
pretty much the full setup. This is a
Death Adder V3 here. I got these, you
know.
It's just my go-to.
Oh, and the webcam here is Razer as
well.
And heck, the computer case and the
mouse mad. And the freaking monitor. I
got a lot of Razer stuff.
we're working on here in Puffer. I'm
trying to add in um
so I'm trying to add in data time steps
as well as uh time spent. So like time
and steps versus time and wall clock and
have these both be part of optim.
Got a whole setup for 500. Nice.
[ __ ] The peripherals I have here are
more than that.
And the the thing with the RA with Razer
stuff is like it actually does improve
every generation. So whenever they
release something new like I kind of
want that
cuz you actually can notice the
difference like most of the time. Like
for instance my uh this thing's all torn
up, right? This like wrist rest is just
all torn up. They made it like they made
it feel nicer and way more durable in
the the next version. They have one of
those at my other place.
Ah, okay. So, this actually does work.
Cool.
Now this is the question as to what we
do for
Fredo points.
Keep dim.
Keep dims.
M silic.
I'm not quite that big now, am I?
The cut's driving me a little crazy, but
I don't know. Not going to be looking
like that, but hopefully should be quite
good soon.
I got to go set myself up like a Dexer
or something.
Oh, this is wrong, isn't it?
How this get messed up.
How do you deal with sleep?
What do you mean?
Actually, so for whatever reason, like
being hungry is the least difficult of
anything.
Like I can basically starve myself and
just not really care that much. It's the
[ __ ] fatigue that's just brutal
because I'm running I'm running probably
average like 40 miles a week and I'm
also lifting five times a week.
Being hungry is just whatever.
Easiest part of the job.
Wait until you have
a kid.
Hey, that's self-inflicted, my guy. You
know what you signed up for.
Oh well. I mean, good for you, man. I uh
at the moment I'm chill and focused on
my research and stuff, though.
Not something I'm going to be thinking
about for quite a while.
Really not my style, man. Really not my
style.
lambda x one line
uh
it's it needs a function it's it's just
a detail of GP cost
it needs it that like specific thing
needs a function
Oh, I'm just dumb, right? Yeah.
Zero.
Uh, I see this just needs a transpose,
right?
T
Yeah, let's just do like this. This will
be better.
I don't even know why I have the stupid
thing in here, right?
This is never freaking used ever.
Get rid of that crap.
Huh.
That's fun.
You doing robotic stuff then? That's
cool.
Why is GPY norm
wait
suggestion scores?
Ah.
transpose needed. I think I transposed
it back
in place with Isaac Sim
and Isaac Sim. Man,
if I ever end up doing like actual hard
robotic stuff, I'm going way lower level
than these engines.
Yeah, that's a cool thing to do. That's
like an actual fun thing to do.
So nice. This isn't Python,
is it?
I don't know. I'm honestly I'm way
happier when I'm writing C.
Okay. Do we have it? Yes, it looks like
we do have it. Very nice. So, if I have
not catastrophically messed something
up, um, what this should now do is this
should attempt to
expand
Let me get this right. They should treat
cost in terms of both
steps and time.
I think I might have to rethink a couple
things.
Hardware is still hard. If I can get you
guys better drones, right, I will gladly
do that. There's actually I totally
forgot to reply to him. Poney in the
Discord.
I think I just like missed his DM or
like I saw it and I totally forgot.
The guy that I talked to said that he
has his lab just has um like crazy fly
drones and then a ton of spare parts
because they get busted a ton.
looking at different hardware but it's
hard to find stuff that's all in stock.
If you message Poney in the uh the
Discord, he might be able to point you
to like a list of stuff. I'm happy to
just send you more like parts and stuff
if we can find stuff to get
and include time steps. So, before Dver
it was we were running almost all of our
experiments, pretty much all of our
experiments just on wall clock time. You
could set it to do steps instead.
Um but what I want is, let me explain.
So this is what I think is going to
become the most important type of graph
in RL.
This is the compute to data tradeoff
frontier right here. Right? So this is
you can spend more data or you can spend
more compute. And then what you're going
to be interested in practically is like
the shape of this elbow, right?
What you're going to end up being
interested is in like the curvature here
based on different problems.
You know how when can we spend more
data, when can we spend more compute?
And then you want to push this frontier
like you want to push it this way,
right? So you could end up like one way
that you could make progress. Um
let me get this right.
Yeah. So like one way you could make
progress is to make the front look like
this so that you know you can you don't
need to spend as much compute and you
can still do well with few samples.
And another way to make progress right
is to make the like the frontier look
like this where um
it like this.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So where you can spend
uh even less computer whatever
or really just to pull this down at all.
So you know this is new. It's not done
yet but like this is the type of thing
that needs to work for RL to be good.
I guess I can run this and see what
happens.
Why don't we just all copy the far right
data points?
Because the far right data points,
this is what Puffer was doing, right?
Which is saying, hey, if I just have
unlimited data, I can train in seconds.
But when you have slower simulators,
this becomes less practical.
So like maybe puffer's been focused on
like actually I can show you exactly
this is where oops
maybe yeah let me explain this very
clearly. Okay so this is where puffer
has been focusing
all efforts is this region here where we
have a ton of data and we can train
super fast. This region up here, like
literally a thousand screens this way,
is academia,
which is why I
uh I complain so loudly about the stuff
that's done there. It's like this
completely impractical frontier over
here.
Uh the actual thing that needs to happen
is we need something that's like
I guess this is 5 mil men. It should
probably be like over here at like 2
mil, but like let's say here, right?
This is where we need to be.
So, I think Puffer is closer to where we
need to be by a mile than where Academia
is, but we still have to do this.
You know, we need to be able to spend a
bit more compute, but not a crazy amount
of compute and use, you know, a fair bit
less data, but not like no data. That's
what we need.
Puff is quietly
is slightly questionable in the UK.
It's just mar. It's like Yeah. People
think it's like a marijuana thing,
right? Is that it?
It's not like a particularly bad double.
Let me let me look this up.
Not on my main screen.
Did I miss something?
Is that actually a thing that you guys
say?
It's like a weird UK slang. What the
heck?
I've never heard that used. Is that
actually like even a remotely common
thing or is that like a super niche
Or is that super niche?
not really used now. I figured it was
like, huh,
y'all have a lot of weird flying in the
UK.
I mean, I'm not going to change stuff
over like if it's like if stuff is
niche.
It's kind of ridiculous, too. like when
uh NIPS decided they were going to
rebrand to Nurips,
even though I guarantee you like they
offended zero people ever.
I nearly died laughing the one time in
uh in grade school that uh like a
British girl asked me if if I had a
rubber. I was like, "What in the heck?"
I was like, "Oh, okay. That's what you
call erasers." Yeah. Uh,
you should you should probably go go
double check that one in the US.
So you talk about the imperial system of
being, you know, pounds, but we have the
imperial system of bullets per eagle.
Working hours shifted minus 6. All
right. So, here's the problem with that,
Tim.
It's very difficult for me to get
through my exercise routine efficiently
because of how tired I am. All right.
And when I get up, I have to uh I have
to go for a six mile run. I've got to do
all my lifts. I've got to get breakfast.
Then I've got to get myself cleaned up
before I can start work.
So, if I'm not feeling super beat up, I
can get all of that done by like
10:30.
If I am feeling super beat up, then it's
going to be 120 or 1.
Government's acting like it's a roaring
80s.
I don't think any country ever has said
their government is all right
other than maybe El Salvador right now.
Yeah, because it's just we're asking
this to pick
we're asking this to pick a cost.
We'll try this and we'll see.
We'll see what happens, I guess.
Hi there. I've started working with
Puffer Libs since I saw you streaming
last and delved into this whole world of
RL trying to wrap my head around rappers
and environments. Welcome. It's a bit of
a messy field, but we're making it much
cleaner.
Okay, I mean, we have this thing at
least good enough.
I may as well do this uh for now.
and things are getting a little less
popular.
Yeah, I think it's mostly the uh the
guys the El Salvadorans who are still in
in the US. Um I mean like literally any
of the Uber drivers here that are from
El Salvador, all they want to do is tell
you how much they love their president.
The drone make the guy
uh crazy fly Sam.
They seem fine. I can definitely get
some I can get crazy flies. I would have
to get you at the very least like a
stack of extra rotors or stuff. They
they basically just keep tons of st
spare parts around because they break
constantly.
Yeah, I'm more than happy to send you
guys one of these plus like some spare
parts and stuff.
Like it's way better than you like
wasting your guys' time having to fight
like stupid hardware. If this is
actually like if you can actually get
this stuff running nicely, I'd be very
very happy to have um no puffer running
real drones.
What is gymnasium docks a good start?
No, gymnasium docks are not a good start
at at all. Um check the stuff on puffer.
Like the thing is we don't even go
through gymnasium except except for
their spaces API. Like the vectorzation
in gymnasium
uh most of the like default libraries
that use their core envi
are just horribly horribly slow and over
complicated.
AI add-on is another What do you mean
the AI add-on?
And that's either way, Finn. That's
still fine if it'll actually work.
Like I just want to see Puffer actually
work on um
I want to see Puffer actually work right
on this stuff.
Okay,
fine.
Working with Jim makes you appreciate
puffer more. Yeah, this
I mean there's just so much in RL that
still needs to be ripped out and
replaced.
It's kind of crazy.
better at these for tomorrow. We ruled
them out. I mean, I told you guys that I
was fine sending you new hardware,
right?
Like, if you think about it, right?
Like, your time is not your time is not
worth nothing. Like, you guys are
capable. If I can just send you guys
slightly better hardware and have
awesome RL working in Puffer, I'm very
very happy to do that. Right?
And then you know that we can have a
cool showcase. We can see a cool thing
working in Puffer. I'm happy with that.
You know, you guys get a cool project
out of it. Maybe we even attract some
industry people and we can set up like
some actual professional stuff that I
could bring you guys on for. A lot of
stuff can come out of that, right?
Looking for lines of constant perf.
No way. I'm just generally I want to
know the frontier, right? The goal is to
have the curve. I want to know the shape
of the curve. And then I want to push
the curve down in any place that we can.
Yeah. Like Sam, like if you guys are
feeling stuck with stupid firmware, like
you can tell me that stuff way earlier.
Like you don't have to drive yourselves
crazy like doing like you know fighting
annoying things, right?
The whole point of a lot of what I'm
doing here, right, is to make RL fast
and easy and sane in whatever way I can.
up contributors have access to advanced
resources.
Yeah. So they sent so in their case they
need hardware because um they sent me
like a really cool drone end of PR and
have been working on that ever since. Uh
generally the thing is that people who
just need like training compute
if you are if you've built like a couple
good environments then I do have
hardware explicitly for that purpose.
So here I have uh was it eight or 10
desktops at this point with 4090s in
them and then we also have a couple
multiGPU boxes. So, typically I just
give uh I give contributors who need
access to a box. I just give them SSH to
one of these boxes. They're all nicely
set up. They've got backup power and all
that.
The curve being points. So, here let me
explain this curve to you.
So each of these points
is an experiment
and specifically I'm filtering these by
experiments that have actually like
mostly solved the uh solved the
environment. So here we have a set of
hyperparameters where we've ran an
experiment and it has solved Pong in 30
seconds after 6.5 million steps. down
here it's solved it in under 10 seconds
but using 24 million steps. So what we
want is we want to know the curve for
like how much data versus how much
compute do we need. These points over
here are just considered bad because
they use they're not Pareto optimal,
right? They use more compute and more
data. That's just worse. So if there's
anything that is if there's anything
that is down and to the right of a
point, it's bad.
Yeah. And Aiz, while I do not I don't
advertise this because I don't like to
like, you know, I don't want to try to
entice people into doing free work for
the potential of doing paid work. It is
true that uh we have had multiple people
get very good and be brought into
professional work with this type of
stuff as well.
There's a much higher bar for that, but
it is a thing. At
So that is the uh that is what I'm
trying to do here.
Oh, we have a fair few folks on YouTube
today. Welcome if you're new around
here. Uh, I do RL research live. I
stream all of my work
and you can find all of it. It's all
open source. Find it on Puffer AI.
We have all sorts of demos here, most of
which are made by contributors, many of
whom came in with no RL experience. If
you're interested in building cool stuff
and actually having RL work on it,
stop by, join Discord.
star follow all that and get involved.
What sort of search you using to find
the curve? How you changing hyperparams
after each new point is added? Another
article on X or that away protein.
Protein is our hyperparameter sweep
algorithm. It is something that I
developed. It is uh based off of MBUI's
carbs algorithm. So of course you know
the successor to it we call protein.
All right. Letting you set up League RL.
Uh better than you would expect.
I think the main qualification I'm
missing in that department is uh simply
not being good enough at league.
freaking hard stuck bronze
documentation is not that clear puffer
rappers work and so on. So Aziz, there
really aren't Puffer rappers is the
thing. Like if you look at other RL
libraries with tons of rappers, like
there isn't documentation because Puffer
does not have them. Like our native
environments do not have rappers at all.
Like if you're like looking at all those
rappers in Gymnasium and being like,
well, why aren't these documented in
Puffer? We don't have them. They're slow
and they're bad.
What comes after protein?
probably creatine.
Imagine the compute needed. Yeah. So
this is I mean one of the things I'm
doing right now right is we're trying to
figure out the compute data tradeoff
because if you had a AAA game with good
state-based obs and you had it running
at the speed of puffer environments we
could solve that very easily.
So in some sense, the only problem that
they have is that their games are not
fast enough, right? AAA game studios. If
they were fast enough, we could just
solve them.
Puffer, I need to work more. Yeah. So as
the if you try to compare Puffer to
existing libraries, you're not going to
have a good time because Puffer is tiny.
like it's tiny compared to a lot of the
other libraries, but it's like just it
learns better, the algorithm is better,
and it's 10,000 times faster in some
places.
So, if you really just go through Puffer
as its own thing, you'll have a much
better time. like the guide that I wrote
as well, like the RL guide that I wrote.
If you follow that, like you will be
solid on RL.
This is how our best contributors have
learned.
Exactly. Just start like basically
follow the guide. You start, it'll tell
you, right? Like read this. Okay, now
build this really simple end. Okay,
cool. Now you can read a couple more
things. You can build a more complicated
end and you build up from there.
is basically I don't really spend a ton
of time. We do have docs, right? But I
spend most of my time not thinking about
like how do I document things better. I
spend most of my time thinking about how
can I delete this stupid thing so it
doesn't have to be documented, right?
How can I make Puffer more compact,
simpler, easier to understand on its
own?
easy to set up.
It's mostly speed. FBR
speed's the main issue.
flare lab fast craft decks. Yeah, of
course. So, um the guys, well, the guy
that writes those is incredibly
talented. I couldn't do that. Uh he
would be able to write those M's and
have free time though if he just did
them in C and they would be faster.
Like you can make jacks work for complex
Ms if you really try, but like it would
just be easier and faster to write them
in C.
Like craft decks is really not fast on
the scheme of puffer environments. Like
a 100,000 steps per second.
If you just ported the thing to see, it
would be like at least a million,
probably more.
So, there's really not even a trade-off
with a lot of this stuff. It's just like
we kind of figured out the way to write
M's and to make everything fast and
easy. And it's just, oh, you do it or
you don't.
The more stuff I see about Jacks, like
at least for environments and
simulation, the more I just think it has
no redeeming qualities.
staying
doing weird things
have any work to be done on it.
Absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely. So, right now, right,
I'm trying to figure out it needs to be
able to better model instead of just one
cost, it needs to be able to model two
costs. That's what I just added. I don't
know if this works yet. The other thing
that's weird to me is
so in protein, one of the big things
that I did was I gave it a down sampled
representation of the entire learning
curve. So instead of just giving it the
um like the last point of your training
curve, you get a down sample like you
get 10 points on your learning curve,
you're getting way more training data
basically.
Uh the problem with this is for some MS
this just doesn't work for some reason.
Like it makes protein not work
correctly.
And then also the Gaussian processes are
like really slow. And I don't know if
there's a way to like just make this
thing run faster or what or to
understand what's going on. I think just
GPS really just don't scale well with
data at all. It's like cubic or
something. But yeah, there's a lot of
work to be done. I mean, I would love to
not have Gaussian processes and pyro and
stuff at all and have like some sort of
other model, but from what I've seen,
it's kind of tough to replace them. But
they're so brittle. Like they're just so
many details.
Um, yeah. I mean, there's a ton of work
to be done on hyper pram sweep stuff,
and making the hyper pram sweep better
would be very, very valuable. I don't
necessarily have a super concrete list
of things though that I would
necessarily go and try to do that other
than just like playing with it more,
running more experiments, that sort of
thing.
the core research task
and good hyperparameter sweeps are
really really useful.
I mean the other thing to think about
right when we're designing our
algorithms
so hyperparameters introduce additional
degrees of freedom right into your
algorithm.
um
the more degrees of freedom you
introduce technically the better you
should be able to do if you tune those
degrees of freedom,
right? But what you want to do is you
want to strike a balance between having
enough degrees of freedom that stuff is
nicely tunable but also not having like
so many degrees of freedom that you need
to run huge huge hyperparameter sweeps
for every new problem, right? like to
what extent can we just find okay you
know we can take out these hyper prams
and we can always do at least 95% as
good as the tuned ones but we don't have
to run so many experiments so on and so
forth
it's quite a bit of work
like for instance right now I have no
idea why the hell it's running so many
experiments with tiny models like it's
just deciding to run all these
experiments with 9,000 parameter models
and I have no idea why the hell it's
doing
Someone working on a tower defense or
did I dream that? I did see somebody
working on a tower defense end in the uh
the Discord. I don't know what happened.
The Discord moves really fast now and
I've kind of been out of the loop.
I really should be like more up to date
on everything, but I don't know. The way
I work a lot of the time, right, is like
I get obsessed with a problem for a few
weeks. I like work hard on the problem
until I solve it or whatever or like I
burn out on it and then like I kind of
got to just chill and think about stuff
for a bit before I work on the next
thing.
I kind of tend to work in cycles like
that.
Best way to look into protein is carbs
paper or protein post. You can go look
at the protein post and then use the
carbs paper to fill in the gaps
and then look at the code, right?
It's actually protein is a simpler
algorithm than carbs in some ways
and the uh the post that I make breaks
it down pretty nicely.
I think that's the like the most math
heavy article I've written though.
Math is kind of annoying in that one.
Like even like the way that they write
down the PTO optimality condition, it's
like this annoying set notation that
takes you like a minute of like thinking
about it to see what the hell they're
even saying because it's you have to
it's like the set of all points such
that for any like for each point there
does not exist a point that is better in
both this metric and that metric or
whatever. But if you just understand
that it's like, yeah, we're looking for
points that are prito optimal with
respect to cost and score.
Okay, if you're a math major, then
you're good. Math is the weakest part of
my toolkit.
So,
it drives me nuts.
This is super weird, right? Like that's
a tiny little network
and that's a solve right there.
like that's actually it just solved with
a a tiny tiny little network.
I mean I don't think it's um
not like a purto point, right? Yeah,
it's right here.
But yeah, it doesn't seem to be
it's not really doing what I would
expect with this. Maybe it is just the
case that pong is so simple that you
just use this tiny little net. I'm
worried that it's like stuck on this
somehow though, right? Like
No, that is including an LSTM.
It's just a tiny LSTM.
Yep. Tiny LSTM.
It's just that it's doing like I let it
go all the way down to 32 hidden
dimension
and it's deciding to run a whole bunch
of experiments at 32 hidden dimension.
I mean to be fair it's
it is getting results I suppose.
I suppose that's the uh the issue as
well with the way that this is set up.
you can actually make 512 hidden fast.
Um you you can definitely make the
networks work at that size as well. We
have problems for which we use even
bigger than that. But
uh the learning rate's going to change
and this is if you integrate mup into
muon then the learning rate should be
able to be stable across model sizes but
right now the learning rate's pretty
dependent on uh the model size.
So that's the key distinction
I missed.
uh did some work to make well I made
some edits to protein to hopefully allow
it to do uh the frontier of compute
versus data cost that's the main thing
at the moment
but it's being super weird like
I mean I don't know what do we think
guys do we think that it's literally
just the case that the smaller model is
better because Pong is really
internet will be solid on chess.
Yeah, I didn't want to give it to you up
front because like
they're kind of a pain to deal with,
but I it seems like it would make sense.
As long as you can get the N to be fast
enough, right?
I think you should be able to make that
work.
It sort of depends sometimes because
like
getting pointer nets to be fast is also
another thing.
Fastish maybe.
You can get it into hundreds of
thousands of steps per second without
too much trouble though. I'm sure of
that.
obs and actions. It's tiny.
It's like
it might it's like four or six numbers.
It's like the positions of the paddles,
the ball, and maybe one or two other
things.
Action spaces just move the paddle.
I think it's like up, down, or like day.
It just it bothers me. This thing has
just run a ton of experiments and they
like just too many of these experiments
are just bad, right?
maximum hidden it solves with. Oh, no. I
can get it to solve with whatever hidden
I want.
But it's the fact that the sweep
algorithm has pushed it to the lowest
possible model size for most of its
runs.
Um, I would doubt it because you don't
get hardware benefits below a certain
point.
I would kind of doubt it.
Oh, you know what? Hang on. I might have
this wrong.
Yeah, hang on. I think I have this
wrong.
It's trying to do sample F
and Okay, I see what's going I see
what's happening. It's trying to do
speed and sample F at the same Time.
Let's see if this does anything
different.
Okay. I mean, it's looking at larger
nets now as well.
So what we want here is we want it to
look for
it's probably going to look at like
smallalish networks
very high throughput and then it's going
to look at larger networks with lower
throughput is the goal.
This is more balanced though.
At the very least
uh length of experiments is only it's
one axis right the length of experiment
that's one cost the other cost which is
the amount of data.
The reason I'm using pong is because uh
you can solve pong in 3 seconds and you
can solve it with less data in like 20
seconds.
So, it's got a very short time out here
and that should be enough to get me a
lot of experiments very quickly.
We'll see what this does.
This has a hope, I'd say.
Trying to think what else we can do
though because I don't I don't like
falling into this trap of like basically
just sitting here for 5 hours watching
experiments and not building stuff.
I also don't like sitting here falling
into the trap of hand tuning
hyperparameters though.
That's super obnoxious.
Like super super obnoxious, right?
Like there's got to be something to do
other than just like a wait for these
stupid experiments to finish repeatedly,
right?
I can push it.
Depends on what like what are you
interested in looking at, right?
Because I can push stuff.
work on an environment.
You know, you're probably right that I
should just like do something like that
because it'll be fun. It'll like that
would be a fun thing to do.
It's so difficult that I like can't
force my mind to do stuff. I'm just like
I don't know.
But the thing is, I don't think that
this problem is going to get solved by
waiting on just waiting around either
everything. Okay, let me let me at least
clean some stuff up on Yes.
more. I want to make
I probably should do some stuff like
that.
I mean, realistically, there's a ton of
stuff there stuff I could be doing.
I'm go look at
look at some old experiments.
The thing is that's too heavy.
Just like I'm not I don't have the
energy for like the these few days here
to be doing that.
That's too much.
I got to get a better logging tool.
Neptune has just gone to [ __ ]
M is to message Jess, I think. Wait, uh
MCM's best way
do some code. Well, but the thing is
Jess, like I can't just procrastinate on
this thing either.
Like this is the most important thing to
be working on right now.
It's just a matter of getting myself to
actually like focus on [ __ ]
Hey, Weston. Welcome.
See if I can fit
I'm just going to see if I can fit
something that's like cleaner here.
Let's see if this makes a difference
already.
this one I don't know to be fair.
Leave it for now.
Okay. So, the hope here is that we've
restricted the search space a whole
bunch.
We just need to be really disciplined, I
think, about
just need to be really disciplined
See, we're already getting somewhere.
There
now. Hopefully this just cranks a bunch
of experiments quickly
and with having like sane defaults for
stuff we can figure out
some sort of fit laws.
And of course we'll have to see like
I guess what we'll try to do is we'll
try to get like a restricted hyper pram
sweep going. We'll like reduce this to
as few axes of variation as is
reasonable.
We'll sweep those so we don't have like
hardcoded pong specific defaults for
anything. Heck, I was fitting the
defaults off of a different an even.
We'll see how good we can get out of
this compared to doing the full sweep.
Basically be able to figure out like
number of degrees of freedom we actually
need to have in this thing.
RAM speed bottlenecks.
I've
I have not measured frankly.
I don't think so, but I have not
measured.
I mean, realistically, you would expect
that the answer is yes, though, right?
Because like
more of a software issue than a hardware
issue. Not doing proper caching
optimization.
All right. Well, I mean, we're at least
we're getting a range of different
experiments now.
I'll be interested to see if this
quickly gives us like a set of usably
good experiments. Right?
That's the the key is if I can just
within a couple of minutes or a few
minutes even just get a a usably good
set of experiments,
start sort of tracking how our hyper
pram sweeps are going. probably way
better.
So like here for instance, right, we
have a solve at 8 million steps.
Check some on this. Here's a restroom
real quick
and build. You'd be tiers of environment
models.
what?
Oh, I miss. Have I been looking for ways
to optimize the physics?
No, I have not looked at that. Um,
so
the thing I'm always skeptical on on
like learned physics models is
uh if you're doing RL against the
models, you're going to poke holes in
it, right? The reason world modeling I
think the reason that world model stuff
at least is supposed to work on paper at
the least is that you're getting fresh
data to patch the holes as you find
them. I don't know if this stuff makes
sense without that.
And heck, for my work on world models,
stuff just doesn't work very well in
general, though. Ton of compute.
All right, I'll be right back. Give me a
minute, folks.
Okay, it's actually uh finding
it's actually found itself some good
experiments already.
This is nice.
Yeah, look at that. It's actually
starting to find good experiments in not
that many trials. That's a a stark
difference, right? That's a very nice
difference.
Now they are all up against the uh
max time but that's
huh
well I mean this is interesting right?
Look at this.
So, we now have
Wait, is that 400K?
Am I reading that right?
It is. Wait, wait, wait. That is
Oh, but wait. No, this is not. Hang on.
I'm dumb.
Yeah. Okay, we're a little dumb here.
All right, that's more reasonable.
Is normalizing inputs
always a good idea for PO?
Um, no. It's just a rough guideline.
Where on the chart is the model
These are all different models, right?
That's the idea.
this is a like 3 million step solve in
30 seconds.
I bother normalizing. You may as well
just divide by if you literally just
divide by four Weston, that's good
enough.
Though if your inputs are one, two,
three, and four, that's a different
story. Now you have categorical data.
Right?
now. Probably there's some reason that
this is at max cost.
Ah, you know what? It's being clever.
It's actually using this to get around
my It's using the time cut off to get
around my constraints
cuz like all it has to do is make the
run slower and slower and it's
technically a parto point, right?
Yeah. So, it's literally just
optimizing. It's trying to find the
slowest run possible.
It depends, Weston. Like if you only
have like zero and one, it's kind of
fine.
It really depends on the data. Usually,
yes,
but it depends.
That's an interesting one, right? 4 mil
2.8. Yeah, that's good.
Like gets added here.
See
I'm trying to think if I need to
massively rethink
maybe I need to rethink the way the
algorithm is going because
the problem is we want to cap the total
time spent
but then if I say like hey fewer steps
is better
that's actually now we have the exact
same problem from before right where
it's like minimum time
or minimum
steps becomes attractive, right? Because
if you can just find the fastest
possible run, that's technically a paro
point. Even though that doesn't freaking
help us at all.
I thought I was supposed to not
have that issue.
I mean, I clearly do see it though. So,
I see it then.
Believing it.
Uh, it's an exploit FBR. It's not it's
an edge case exploit that I'm dealing
with. It's not like a poor thing. What's
the Y axis? So I they're two different
charts. The main thing we're trying to
figure out is we're trying to figure out
like data efficient runs and compute
efficient runs.
Wait, this shouldn't have the same
degeneracy, right?
Yeah, I actually I explicitly designed
it like I was smarter than that, right?
I like explicitly designed it to handle
this.
I don't like that all of the experiments
here are above 30 seconds.
The two different costs are competing,
right?
Instead of doing a minute, would be
easier to just do half of one and half
of the other. No.
That way I don't have to deal with like
relative normalization horseshit.
That just actually did that just did
something, didn't it?
Yeah. Look at that.
Out here, we got this point.
This also doesn't give us our nice
burrito front now, does it?
Yeah, these tools like actually um
these tools here are not designed for
this at all.
Kind of tempted to do my own custom log
thing.
This would give us a nicer burrito
frontier as well.
I do wish I had my local machine
for this because otherwise it's actually
kind of obnoxious to try to um
It'd be kind of funny if I just did it
in Ray Lib, wouldn't it?
In my own damn plots.
I could do it really easily, actually.
Be funny.
I suppose
This can bias you one way or the other,
right?
Okay. But at least we have something
more respectable now, right?
Like a good baseline.
Okay.
And do the same thing now There.
So, we're going to spend half of the
time looking for sample efficient runs
and half the time looking for data
efficient runs.
Yeah, we got basically we got 50-ish
runs here, right? Let's look at our
samples.
Uh over time they do get more accurate
on
doing well, but they also all clumped up
in the high time zone, right?
So it kind of only filled out.
So like this one here,
it really didn't fill out much of a
front, right?
He kind of just did a bunch of long
runs.
It looks like it was just trying to win
on samples mostly, right?
A couple exceptions.
Yeah. Look, you can see it's pushing
down over time. It was just trying to
win on samples.
Not what we want. We want explicitly
this thing to cover both cases, right?
Okay. So now we should be able to do
that.
We should be able to do that much more
explicitly.
Now we don't have the normalization
thing going on.
Trying to think what the smartest thing
to do is when
I don't want to be building my own
stupid dashboard application, but like
did that during my PhD. Actually,
there's some super old screenshots you
can probably still find from my PhD
where I had like my own custom dashboard
for Nurmmo.
I could just have it save
like a nice plot image, I suppose.
It's difficult when I can't even say
exactly the format of the thing like the
thing that you need to be monitoring.
Think I can probably something to work
though before I fully know that
goes up think
trying to solve
I mean, they're kind of two separate
issues.
I suppose I could do like pure sample f
Right.
If we were to give this thing a one
minute timeout,
just go purely on sample efficiency.
What does it do?
It's doing good stuff at the moment to
be fair.
Maybe we can just do it this way.
but is this going to get both sides?
And so far,
we've got these two
is reasonable
I mean, we know how this should
technically work, right?
Their puffers in the spaceport, too work
is another story.
Like technically it should be it should
be stuff like fewer environments, more
updates,
that sort of thing should improve sample
And this is a ton. This is going to be a
high samples.
super fast one.
oh no, this is good, right? Like
it's going down this way
on both sides.
Maybe this is it. Maybe we actually have
gotten it.
It'll have to be uh a question of how
much Better.
It always runs for way too long is the
other thing.
is stop
with steps and sample.
I actually wonder if the down sampling
is messing.
What did we find here? It's 4 million
10 seconds.
Yeah. So, we actually we already found
something better with this than with the
old method. So, that's good.
Yeah, this is an improvement.
Down sampling is messing it up, I
suppose.
That's a really good result. Wait, what?
Isn't it?
Okay.
I think we've gotten it, guys.
That's good.
That's very good.
then it knows right like that
technically believe this point's also
Purto. This is sub 3 million.
Oh, this uptime thing is not even the
it's actually a little faster than this
as well.
Hey FBR.
So if you think of this right like the
original puffer lip baseline is 3
seconds for 12 million steps.
What this says is that we can instead of
spending 3 seconds, we can spend 8
seconds and we can cut the amount of
data that we need in three
potentially. Very good.
And look at that. It's actually filling
in nicely now. You see, it's like
looking for runs.
I do actually wonder though with this
cost thing.
I have another thing to try after this.
We're giving these like 50 runs a piece,
I think.
I have another thing to do.
Straight up steal your ID and beat you
to it for paper submission.
I mean, you can do and it'll be
published, but if you don't give
attribution
going to end up in
not looking too good.
I don't particularly care if people want
to formalize and publish my stuff as
long as it's attributed
because I'm sure as hell not doing it.
I'm doing blog posts now.
I mean, it's just dumb. Honestly,
academic like drama is just so stupid.
Just like shut up and actually improve
science.
Get out.
What we change here?
If this makes any sense actually
Let me think.
Log costs.
The crazy thing to me is if you like
actually read academic papers like as a
whole in this field like
A used car salesman is going to be more
honest than your typical paper with the
way that the results are presented.
I actually don't know if this needs to
go negative or not.
Maybe this is just fine.
I think it can go. We'll try this next.
But this is like a pretty solid.
Okay. Okay. I mean, this is pretty solid
for our set of 50 runs here, Okay.
You literally don't even have to do
that.
This will attempt to do
cheaper and more expensive runs.
Um
if you have appropriate credentials then
pretty much Yeah,
dude. Silicon Valley founded [ __ ]
Theronos. Like come on.
Okay.
I mean this is a result like a decent
start.
We can just leave this. I'm going to
This is Well, we're going to see if this
beats it. And then after that, I think
we're going to just leave this to run
longer.
And we'll see what this does.
It's funny that we don't have points
down here, right?
But presumably
presumably those will get in uh explored
eventually.
There's only 50 runs.
Let me find Let me think of something
else. Let's try to see if I can think of
something else I can do or some other
way I can start making progress here
because I really don't want to spend all
week just like staring at little fiddly
experiments.
we make multiGPU sweeps just work.
be really nice, wouldn't it?
That would actually be the best thing is
if we could just get multiGPU sweeps
compile working. Uh
I think it should be, but I haven't used
it in a while now. But we don't do
compile during sweeps because it
literally takes longer. It takes longer
to run the compile on short experiments
than the time you would save from it.
I think what's the simplest way that we
could get multiGPU
sweeps,
something crashes, you're not going to
get the freaking error. But
Well, there's not a standard in Puffer
because we don't do it normally.
We don't have action masks in Puffer by
default. Weston you would add it by some
way and you would add it by masking out
illegal actions. The way that you mask
out illegal actions is typically unless
you're going to change the sampling,
you'd have to set logits like negative
infinity or something, right?
No for inputs.
Wait, what? No for inputs.
I don't know.
parallels.
What
output props?
Yeah. So like if you look at the
sampling logic, right? When we call
sample logets, I think you'd have to set
the inputs of invalid actions to
negative infinity or whatever
or add it as a feature to do the same
thing.
I don't like the idea of having to
subrocess freaking
me nuts.
Can't thread it though because Python
doesn't have.
I could subprocess for now and like
we'll eventually replace with the reds
and triple triad doesn't have action
masking.
Oh, also that's like one of the MS that
has really bad code by the way. That's
like Spencer's literal first M that he
made.
Crazy nested pointer shenanigans.
use his action mask. Dispatch
your loop cycles through. It's You can't
just do that.
I need I'm at the very least going to
have to throw the whole train thing into
a subprocess, which I hate.
well because you need the CPU. It's a
CPU intensive thing as well.
I should merge. Let me finish this.
We'll merge this and then we'll try to
do this on another like on the multiGPU
box
to play.
If I can get this to work, it would
actually make a big difference.
be fair.
and this has not produced a single thing
of worth. So,
train and name parts. Okay,
I think we can do this, right?
Do I not have my super maven on this?
Oh, I don't. Damn it.
So obnoxious.
I want higher.
Yeah. I don't know.
uh yeah, there's something to world
models, but
I mean it's the it's like the same old
same old where the quality of the lit
just sucks. feel like
I'm not spending my time cleaning up
everybody else's messes when I have
other things I can do to improve such
Good.
Can I just like
want to do this on the box that actually
has a freaking
That's okay. Going on this.
All right. So, some like something like
this. Yeah,
ever done anything with robotics? Uh, I
mean, we have the drone m. We haven't
done We've also done stuff in animation
with
uh like Isaac Jim, old Isaac gym.
We haven't gone super heavy into
robotics.
I honestly don't think it's going to be
the biggest area for RL at all.
I honestly do want to spend more time on
material science. There's just some jank
stuff with um there's like some still
some jank fundamentals
to be addressed.
Like it just it feels wrong for me to
step like very deeply into a specific
application area um with the state of
the field still being what it is, right?
Like
we can totally get stuff to work
Like we can totally get stuff to work and we do for clients, right? But like
and we do for clients, right? But like
and just be way better.
30?
Now I am actually still Now I am
actually starting to get hungry.
restrict
like keyword arg only restrict.
Yeah, because it's stupid and Python's a
stupid language with too many stupid
features.
Honestly, we use too much. We use too
many of the stupid features as is.
You mean like star in a list so that you
like it mandatory keyword arcs?
You mean like the man like mandatory
keyword args?
And wait, what?
Destruct
star.
Yeah, cuz I don't know what the hell
that is. What does that even do?
I thought you were talking about
something completely different.
I didn't know about that keyword. That's
weird.
A lot of lower level optimizations,
um, you actually need to either know
quite a bit about how the compiler works
or you need to time aggressively to see
if it does anything.
Do a lot of We don't do a lot of subp
pointers though.
What?
I have no idea the distinction you just
made.
We wouldn't have this issue if it was
written in Haskell. Yeah, because we
would have all uh [ __ ] You're not
allowed to even say that on the [ __ ]
whatever.
I would not be in this line of work if I
had to write everything in Haskell.
Let's say
Oh,
so annoying.
You're going to have to send me a proper
example somewhere. Weston
Like you just you have to be a little
bit careful because if you're not timing
[ __ ] like you can come up with all sorts
of things to help the compiler and you
just make a mess of your code with like
a bunch of extra keywords and [ __ ] and
then it's the exact same or worse.
right, we'll look. Did you actually time
it?
I have to see the code differences and
such
kind and it asks that there's just like
more keyword
Like what could you have not written
without this keyword There.
Okay. Well, Grock is [ __ ] with you,
so
you don't need to do
you don't
You shouldn't need to be doing that on
your own because the thing is
puffer bindings is just taking care of
that for you. And if I were going to do
this, if I were going to do this in C,
like
each end for each block of M's would
just get its own thread.
I sure as hell wouldn't be doing
trying to do multicore anything with a
bunch of macros.
I'm not saying it doesn't work. I'm just
saying you're making stuff complicated
on yourself.
need to write C code to create a custom
M. You can write Python for custom M
though we highly recommend that you try
the C. Um it's just it's going to be
very very fast and it's going to be a
lot easier than you expect if you look
at some of our examples.
Uh that is the the recommended though
for custom MS is yeah that you use our
native API. You can also bind existing
like gymnasium and petting zoo m in
about one line very quickly, but I mean
for the most part you're never going to
get close to the speeds that you can get
with our native MS.
I don't necessarily think that helps
honestly because if you're thinking in
Python you're going to do it wrong. I
would check like our like we have a
template end C. I'd suggest just copying
that and using it as a starting point.
This is why I didn't want to do freaking
subprocess [ __ ]
a little bit.
We have guides on X. If you click if you
click my articles tab,
there's a comprehensive guide that will
get you started with Puffer.
And so this loop actually does run
enough.
It's just Python being [ __ ] Like this
would be way easier if um the thing I'm
doing is not like normal with upper and
it's only like this is literally just
Python being a terrible language.
Honestly, this should be fixed in Python
314 though. And then um we'll actually
be able to thread instead of having to
do this horrible mess.
Oh, that's terrible.
You're going to break everything, I'm
sure.
Oh yeah, this is I don't have my normal
editor on this box.
This is just like default vanilla Vim.
I don't even have my code complete
plugin on this. I kind of just been
writing stuff.
It really goes to show you though, the
fact that I can do this and it's like
not that much worse.
The AI like the plugins really don't do
that much. mostly just on you.
blogs it the thing is I I did write um
so it's on the website as well
but
we there is a comprehensive guide smog
like most of this stuff is just in
articles
Like if you read this, this is a
detailed guide. This has links to
everything else. Uh this is all you need
right here. This is a complete reference
with everything that's linked. It's a
lot of material to work through.
Isn't it cuda colon? Is that do I have
it wrong?
Uh that document is though like
that's not dated.
code examples that has code examples
though is the thing that has like
extensive code examples. It's just that
they're linked to from there instead of
being inlined because if I inline them
then I have to keep them updated all the
time, right? Whereas if I have them
linked then they're automatically kept
updated
here.
If you actually look through this thing,
right,
it says, "Okay, do this on the squared
environment." Cool. This is in puffer
li, right? Uh then there's where's the
other one? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Here it
says read the docs. Okay. Docs.
We start here.
Here's this thing. Okay, we go here.
Here's code, right? And then we go back
here. Okay, here's code.
Here's code, right? It's like it's all
linked. There's not a ton of stuff
inlined because it gets outdated, but
like there is a bunch of code. It's
linked. There are like, you know, many
hundred lines, probably many thousand
lines worth of examples in here.
working environment. there is working in
well it's not like it's integrated on
the site where it's like you have the
code on one side and the end like yeah
there's not UX done on that type of
stuff or whatever but
the stuff is there
I really don't like any of these like
fancy organizational apps for thoughts
and knowledge and such.
I don't know. I whenever I was made to
take notes in like school and like
college, right, I literally would never
once read them
and I was like, "Okay, what the [ __ ] is
the point of this?"
Yeah, but that type like
I don't know.
I used to think like, oh, I should be
more organized. I should do this. I
should do that. And then it's like I
tried various things and it's there's
really just no substitute for the very
simple approach I've taken. It helps
some people. It doesn't help me for like
at all.
Like I want less structure if anything.
You all know I've made it when I have no
public email, no calendar, no other
sorts of things of the type at all.
I I work on um a like I hone in on a
problem. I work on it very hard for a
few weeks at a time. I look at it in a
ways that it hasn't been looked at
before. I solve the thing. I either
write up or put out, you know, a piece
of work on that thing that I've done.
And then I take some time to think and
regroup and I go to the next one. What
time is it here? My watch should be
charged, right? 5:30, 5:20 something. I
usually go to dinner at 6:00 and I am
starving.
We're going to see how much longer I'm
doing this cut for. Um, I said that I
was going to keep this up though until
either I'm done with California
or until it starts uh until I start
losing strength. This is week five. I am
hungry.
The results have been very good so far
though.
California Palo Alto is nice in the
summer and there's business around
your chat mainly Europeans. It depends
what time I'm streaming, right?
understand what you're seeing.
If you stick around, you will see like
it's actually a lot easier to get into a
lot of this stuff than you'd expect. We
have brand new programmers who have
gotten RL working on new M's that they
have written that are fast in C. So,
I mean, RL is like a thousand times
easier to get into than it was a year
and a half ago before Puffer
knows how to party. I used to know how
to party.
I did too much of it and got sick of it.
So weird,
right?
Some of us have running at 10K.
That's on you.
new graphic. Should I write in C? Yes,
you should write in C. We use Ray for
graphics. Ray is really really nice and
easy to use.
Like
so graphics is basically taken care of
for you because we it's just the best
library ever to use.
And the end logic, the way that that is
hooked into Puffer is made very easy for
you. You pretty much just get to do
low-level gamedev or low-level whatever
your application is dev.
Yeah, Rayb is great. Like Ray is truly I
got to say Ray is the best library I've
ever used.
Yeah, I've got to give it to the library
that's pure C, right? Because like if
we're looking at Python stuff, like
yeah, there's NumPy. Numpai is
revolutionary for that. like
many GPUs. Oh yeah. So um
the other cool thing about Puffer is we
have hardware and we do give repeat
contributors access.
Where is it?
I will show you the Puffer training
facility.
So, I missed this place. I will be back
there after I'm done in California.
We have all the hardware in the back in
the background for training agents. Then
we have all the equipment for training
me.
That was fun. The two tiny boxes there
are six GPUs a piece.
I think I should still be able to be
lifting this no problem. And I'll
probably be like 15 lbs lighter than
when I left.
Oh yeah. This
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
You have to be really stubborn
is the thing.
But it doesn't seem like it's way
faster, right?
X article on my gym stuff. I do post the
occasional fitness article.
There will be one on the um the training
block that I've been running for the
last month
soon
when I finish it.
I'm still not sure whether I want to
post um
post physique pictures because I don't
usually post I don't usually do that.
But the results of this one have been
very good
and unlike um normally I normally I'm
posting stuff that's like you know a
strength goal or like a running goal or
something. Uh but the main thing with a
cut right is the physique difference.
No, it's Sloth is LLM's, man. Like the
stuff that we do has to be a thousand
times better optimized than any of the
LLM stuff that's out there. It's a
totally different data regime.
Like basically anything that's been
designed for LLMs will just fail
hilariously.
Yes, Jess. It's one of the things I get
the most number of people emailing me
about.
Speaking of which, I was supposed to
talk to a guy today, but I forgot.
Biggie
tired.
I'm really just exhausted this week. I
don't know. It's probably the cut.
Probably with less food I should be like
go get myself a vitamin supplement or
something. See if that helps.
But I think it's most likely just the
damn cut. Thanks, Mog. There is a
Discord, discord.gg/puffer
if you're interested in that. Lots of
helpful people on there. Pretty much
everyone on the uh the stream is on
there as well.
Yeah, you're just kind of in a tough
spot, man. It gets better.
Why did I try to write a print f in
Python? Can somebody tell me that?
Ah, it's trying to suggest a billion
things.
Okay, this is actually now faster,
right? There's some overhead,
but it's faster.
Yeah, that's actually substantially
faster. Perfect.
7.6 seconds under 3 mil.
Solid.
We'll see how this goes.
Big sweep multiGPU
initial test.
The first multiGPU sweep I've had going,
at least with this algorithm nicely. We
got a chunk of multipprocessing work
done today.
We got
nice new baselines running.
This thing's still going as well.
Check this out. Right,
we have this nice thing here
this graph.
We can just go
that we want all of the solves
take 70 different runs and then our best
here. We have our front
couple over here so on and so forth.
Very nice.
That's a decent chunk of work done for
now.
I'm going to go get dinner before I
starve to death.
A couple people that are still here
watching, thanks for tuning in.
It's going to be a little bit more slow
work for a bit until we get uh into a
bigger new project.
But this type of stuff's important. Like
if we get this to work, this will just
be so much more polish on Puffer and
this will let us like this will
basically let us throw Puffer on a lot
of new types of problems very
effortlessly.
All right, cool. Well,
uh my stuff is at puffer.ai.
This live stream is supposed to be Okay,
that's messed up. But anyways, start the
uh the start of the repo helps me a lot.
Join Discord, want to get involved and
follow me on X for more content.